la unión europea quiere evitar que se
descontroló por completo la situación
por la tercera ola del coronavirus en la
unión europea por ello apunta a los
viajes dentro de sus fronteras la
comisión europea propone aislar a la
práctica a todas las zonas y países con
incidencia acumulada de 500 casos por
100.000 habitantes algo que afectaría
especialmente a españa y portugal a
todos los viajeros que provengan de
estas zonas se les obligará a que tengan
un test en negativo antes de viajar y se
les obligará a una cuarentena a su país
de llegada
tampoco se descartara un segundo test
para evitar casos en que se pueda
importar el virus la comisión europea
quiere evitar a toda costa que la gente
pueda viajar dentro de la unión europea
con una especial atención a las nuevas
variantes también se vigilará a los
pasajeros que provengan de países donde
ya se han confirmado los casos lo que
quiere la unión europea es sobre todo
por una parte evitar los viajes y a la
vez también vigilar a las nuevas
variantes mucho más peligrosas debido a
su mayor transmisibilidad
además este momento es muy delicado para
la unión europea en plena campaña de
vacunación especialmente ahora que
astrazéneca y también facer ya han dicho
que no cumplirán con el calendario de
producción y esto podría retrasar
muchísimo más la campaña de vacunación
dentro de la unión europea